at the bottom of the table our Eritrea
Turkmenistan and North Korea reporters
without borders classify the lack of
press freedom in those countries as very
serious Sudan is also in that category
but last year's mass protests that led
to the ousting of President Omar
al-bashir have resulted in stronger
democratic structures and reduced
restrictions for journalists as a result
the country ranks 16 points higher on
the index than last year
countries that made similar improvements
include Malaysia and Ethiopia
while poorer ratings are given to the
West African state of Benin which fell
17 places and Haiti down 21 the
Caribbean nation is struggling with an
ongoing political crisis and violent
protests in the past year journalists
there were repeatedly attacked one was
killed the United States ranks at 45th
place this year after two years of
decline the situation has slightly
improved over the last year but
reporters without borders cite the US as
a worrying example of hatred incited
against journalists by elected
politicians with verbal and physical
attacks against reporters alarmingly
frequent Germany ranks at 11th place
also up two places from last year the
main reason for this is a decline in the
numbers of attacks against journalists
but reporters without borders say
they're still concerned for the
protection of journalistic sources the
country's ranking highest for press
freedom remain in Scandinavia Denmark
Finland and Norway
and the report also showed that the
Philippines has dropped two places to
136 out of 180 countries and someone who
knows what that means is journalist and
author maria reza who's had several
run-ins with the government she joins me
now from manila maria very good to have
you on the program what is it like being
a journalist in the Philippines now I
think the first thing is that the world
seems like it's never gonna be the same
again we're in our sixth week of
lockdown and there had president - Ted -
signed an emergency powers law on March
24th that gives him tremendous power
including an insertion that essentially
could allow authorities to jail anyone
for a month two months and fined them
about $20,000
I mean you are somebody who has
experience with this don't you I mean
there are at last call nothing you had
about seven cases if that's the correct
count against you from the Philippine
government I mean are you afraid that
the Philippines government is using the
coronavirus crisis to gain more control
over the media look I think that what
we're seeing is a government that is
trying very hard to deal with a pandemic
this is like I said six weeks in right
and we have to decide the government has
to decide whether it will stay or lift
the this kind of lockdown on April 30th
they have their hands full having said
that 30,000 people have been arrested
for ant for quarantine violations and
then we had a former congressman and his
team who were out distributing relief
goods arrested and charged with sedition
so these two things are going
hand-in-hand yes
journalists more than ever the mission
is much more important because not only
are you trying to hold government
account you're also trying to make sure
that our citizens have the right
information and at the same time to tell
them that we need to keep asking for
facts right so it's a yeah I think in a
strange way we've been under attack for
four years in Rattler this is an
extension of that but it is also a very
different time where
tire nation our entire world is under
attack do you think that moving forward
things are gonna get worse for you in
the Philippines and for media freedom in
the Philippines before they get better
I think there are two problems that
we're going to have to face post
lockdown the first is really can-can
independent news group survive this
right our business more than at any
other time is under attack cash flow is
king you're going to see a recession if
not a depression in many countries
around the world so that's the first
step the second one is we've got to go
out and do our jobs even more because
our people need this
Maria Ariza pleasure talking to you
thank you so much thank you